hurricanes are well-known in the
Atlantic and in the Caribbean but
scientists in California are concerned
that changing climate conditions could
soon bring hurricanes to the west coast
Jamie yuccas has the story Irma Harvey
and Katrina are among the Hurricanes
that have ravaged the East Coast and
Gulf of Mexico but here in California
hurricanes are virtually unheard of
what are you do in that case of a
hurricane I don't know I can't imagine
like that kind of devastation hearing
the shores here hurricanes that form in
the eastern Pacific Ocean usually don't
make it past Baja California only one
managed to reach as far as San Diego in
1858 however there's now the potential
this rare event could strike the San
Diego area again oceanographer art
Miller it could happen especially if the
ocean temperatures continue to stay in
this anomalously warm state it's very
simple scientists at the Scripps pier
have been recording historic
temperatures in the Pacific Ocean as
high as seventy nine point five degrees
that's about ten degrees above normal
but what has the temperature gauge
showed you over the last week or so it's
shown that we have been right at or
outside the record temperatures that
were already set back in the 30s so we
know that we are experiencing a very
extreme temperature event that
potentially increases the likelihood
that a hurricane might track just a
little bit further north than it would
have even though California has been
battle tested by fires mudslides and
earthquakes the widespread impact of a
hurricane on lives and property is still
unknown a risk associated with those
high wind events might be surprising
since we really haven't been tested for
that type of natural phenomenon
the National Weather Service has found
even higher temperatures in other parts
of the Pacific that's because the ocean
absorbs more heat than it does on the
land also the normal Southern California
winds have not been picking up which
would allow cooler waters to mix in
scientists believe the warming trend
will continue for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie yuccas along the Southern
California coast those rising ocean
temperatures are startling startling and
when you think about 10 degree
difference as you pointed out and think
about it's been a year since hurricane
Harvey it was this time last year right
and it was warm ocean waters feeling
that as well yeah I mean you also think
all the disasters as Jamie mentioned
that they have to deal with already that
on top of it cannot imagine the
destruction there